i'm not sure if you've noticed recently
but i'm a huge sports fan and recently
i've noticed how espn's becoming really
left-wing and how they're
embracing that caught on yeah in the
anthem yeah i know big mystery right
um i also got a follow-up question after
this but i'm just saying why is espn
embracing that left lane politics and to
their audience
okay so i think that some of it is
bubble think
and some of it i think is actual market
research that's driving them to the left
so
so the the bubble think is pretty simple
most of the people in sports media exist
on the coast they exist in new york or
l.a
they exist in big media markets those
big media markets lean left so the pool
from which they're drawing
is a bunch of people who are left uh the
the sport the the the
market research that i'm talking about
and i actually have done a pretty deep
dive on espn because i used to watch
espn
incessantly i used to love espn i used
to be a subscriber to sports illustrated
i canceled my subscription circa 2015
when they when every week it seemed they
were putting caitlyn jenner on the cover
someone who had not been athletically
relevant since before my birth
and so at that point i was like okay if
i want to read about transgenderism i'll
get people magazine if i want to read
about sports please give me some news
about
a sport involving involving balls
but
[Applause]
okay
and went somewhere i wasn't expecting
but you know um
so uh so i think so here's here's what
the market research says
the market research says that espn
spends an outsized amount of time
focusing on the nba
they think that's the real growth area
is the nba and if you look at the
the constituency of people who watch the
nba uh it is it is disproportionately
black folks who watch the nba
uh and are watching longer hours
typically young black men are watching
the nba in larger numbers those people
tend to be more politically to the left
and that means that espn
is skewing to the left in order to pick
up some of those viewers that at least
would not be illogical that at least
make a certain amount of sense
i think it's a big mistake on their part
because i think that uh number one i
love the mba i love watching the nba but
i don't want my my
nba infused with politics i think black
folks are just as likely to watch the
nba whether it's infused with politics
or not when we all tune into espn i
think we all are
wanting to watch the same thing and i'm
not really that concerned about
what lebron james message is putting on
his sneakers on opening night
and i'm much more concerned with are
these people good at basketball
um so i think it's a mistake by espn i
think they're losing subscribers hand
over fist and i think that they should
but i think that's probably
the combined reason behind the move to
the left